no uh the comedy store is like the
[ __ ]
mecca right the [ __ ] right of combat
it's like the hub
right that's like yeah man it's like
you know you catch big people there
there's just yeah
that's cool like it was like you know
because they were like all those you
know big dogs like
you know they all be out on tour and
when
uh they they all used to get better like
monday
tuesday night the comedy store was one
of the most popping nights
they just popped in why is that cause
like they they all go on the road like
thursday through okay sunday get back
monday have a little rest
tuesday nights i mean there was there
was stuff going on every night it was
still like good
you know through the rest of the nights
but let me tell you that tuesday night
right when everybody was getting back
into town tuesday wednesday nights
extraordinary man wow [ __ ] like so
what do they do on those nights
they they come to the club it's just
it's just the [ __ ] lineups
okay you know you can see
[ __ ] you know whitney elizabeth
um [ __ ] rogan
diaz you know all you like you see this
[ __ ] massive
lineup delia everybody you see this
one ali wong [ __ ] neil brennan
annie letterman [ __ ] just right there
right there for you that's so cool
that's so wild man right there for you
and it's like
you you're seeing them like back to back
like you can't get that anywhere else
no you cannot get there anywhere else
you know you've seen the [ __ ] for
anything not for music
no you're seeing the [ __ ] biggest
people
yeah biggest people in the comedy game
you know i mean so
[ __ ] crazy miss pat [ __ ] punky
johnson just [ __ ]
i bet you got some good ass stories from
the comedy store due to the experiences
yeah man that's um that's how i met
rogan
you know that's how i became cool with
him yeah um just based off of genuine
conversation
you know really yeah they have this
program at the comedy store called the
development spot program
okay and that's how you work your way up
to like being a paid regular
and so you like come in and you do these
you know you like call in
once a week and give your availability
and you know they'll
give you um you know a spot
that week or whatever um it's like a
five minute spot
the very top of the show um
and i was on one that where rogan was on
the lineup
and um i was sitting back there and
usually like
you know i'm pretty quiet in those like
areas you know when it's like all those
big dogs around you know because they're
they know each other they're doing their
thing and i'm just you guys are all in
like a room beforehand
it's like backstage okay yeah so
everyone's like yeah everyone's just
like waiting to go
see like yeah your [ __ ] idol right
over there yeah yeah just sitting right
across from me
you know and i you know i was just more
quiet you know because it's like they
all know each other i'm you know just
you know a young young cat in the game
yeah
and um he just
he goes hey what's up man just and we
just started talking from there man we
just
got deep you know we started talking
about books started talking about
you know i told him i was a cheerleader
he was geeking out over that he was
cheerleader and he was i was like yeah
you know i showed him you know some
videos and he was like what the [ __ ] he
was blown
away it's mind-blowing yeah he was like
blown away which i was like you know
i you know i guess i just don't expect
people to be blown away by it because
it's just like
i was a cheerleader yeah um but yeah and
then
you know as i'm leaving i was like all
right you know pleasure meeting you
you know i'll see you around joe and he
goes oh wait wait what you what's your
instagram man i'll follow you
and then i was like oh [ __ ] yeah they
started following me and then uh
and then instagram [ __ ] started
getting flooded after that yeah yeah
yeah and then he uh then he he go he hit
me up like
a couple days later he goes hey man you
know i'm uh
doing a show at the store um at 10 p.m
you know was wondering if you want to be
on it do i
oh actually [ __ ] kid no
oh man yeah and then you know he asked
me to be on it i was like [ __ ] yeah
you know and ever since then you know
he'd just be
real [ __ ] cool with me man that's
just cool you know
help me out wherever he he [ __ ] could
you know
he's a he's a great great dude you know
what i mean and
um you know and it's so weird like
like the people that don't understand
them you know just think that's that's
the funny thing about you know people
because you know
he gets he gets some hate from people
that don't understand
you know or really know about the comedy
world not in the uh not not someone's in
the comedy world just by you know
people in german i think there was
something where like spotify were like
if you don't censor joe rogan
oh yeah and
is that real i guess so i don't know how
real
that's what i'm asking i'm like how real
is that i didn't know if that
actually i was like are they just saying
that right i don't know but i you know
obviously
like i know that they didn't put any of
his alex jones [ __ ] on spotify yeah i'm
not gonna bug him about to be like hey
man
yeah you know yeah exactly yeah
you know he's probably already getting a
lot but um
um you know it's it's it's wild when you
when you see
people do those kind of things and
that's when you it's like oh you think
you know this person have you ever had a
conversation with this person
then how do you know this person right
just based off of what you
like yeah yeah you listen to podcasts
you know you
it probably most of these people don't
even [ __ ] listen to the full podcast
you know what i mean clips they're just
getting clips which is like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's like those
like when someone drops the article
you know many people read a full article
not many [ __ ] people
right so that that's the thing and um
it's like you don't even know this
person
this person doesn't even know you you
never had a conversation with this
person
why do you think you know this person
why do you think you know this person
why do you think you know
what the [ __ ] you know why why
why why like what so why are you saying
these things
you know what i mean i don't know
anything about kim kardashian
yeah i'm not gonna sit there and be like
yo what the [ __ ] is she doing
why is she such a [ __ ] i don't know
i don't know who she is i don't know she
doesn't know me right what does she owe
to me
yeah you know what i mean like that's
the um
thing like that that can be wild in this
[ __ ]
world like that's what we were talking
about earlier with the podcasts like
yeah the the difference between like
produced
reality shows on tv versus these
podcasts like you're saying like
there's like a whole mecca of people in
la there's like a huge podcast scene
like a very con
i feel like it's very condensed like
there's like the theovon
there's joey i think joey has moved
didn't he yeah he moved but he's doing
his own
he's still doing like podcasting and
then you do a bunch of stuff with uh
brandon
brandon shop and um brian cowan all
those guys they all have podcasts and
they're all comedy guys
yeah i think that's like a it's like a
like a weird little revolution
kind of going on yeah well because i
mean like you know
the thing is is when you become a
comedian it used to be this model
you became a comedian you got a tv show
mm-hmm he's like you you get a
you get a seinfeld you get a martin
right you got a steve harvey show
you get you know you get these shows
yeah bernie mac show
yeah that was the thing that was that
was the thing that took you
to the [ __ ] highest level that was
you know
that's getting used to sell out theaters
arenas
you know but that's not the case anymore
you know
you you you know with the podcast you're
shooting the [ __ ]
you know there's so many options of
different types of podcasts that you
that people can listen to
people find the ones that they like you
know what i mean and
and you know podcast fans are really
you know die-hard fans yeah yeah you
know what i mean because yes
you know we are talking more real than
we are we're not we're not characters
right right right now we're not being a
character right now we're not being
produced or told what to do
yeah exactly there's no script there's
nothing to it we're sitting here
we're chatting right so you know with
the
you know
people are diehard fans of ross the guy
from friends
yeah they're not die-hard fans of i
don't know we don't even know his
[ __ ] real name
know but they look at him they go ross
yeah right they want to say ross they
want to call you ross
mm-hmm yeah you know um and it's so
funny because i've never even [ __ ]
seen
friends but but i just know i just hear
people talk about all the [ __ ] time
um but like it's it's like that where
it's like you know
this is just a genuine conversation you
know
and but like but also like
you know the downside of that is that
people really think they know you and
want to talk to you
as if like you're their friend too like
sometimes i'll get messages from people
where i'm like
i don't know who you are yeah and they
want to talk to me
you know in a way that we all talk
like it's like cold calling somebody on
the phone like i don't know
like you're just calling hey man i
totally yeah you know like yeah i don't
know i don't know your energy like how
do you already
right i can't gauge this like you can't
just come in yeah there's no foundation
for this conversation yeah there's no
foundation with a conversation i was
like
how about a hey first right right you
know that that'll be a [ __ ]
hi my name is yeah yeah exactly
it's just [ __ ] that just you know you
know i'm pretty sure you guys probably
get it too where you just
you know people just reach out to you
and and they mean you know well they
don't mean
harm you know they they want to just you
know they they're fans of you and they
want to say things right you know what i
mean they want to talk the way you know
put it
you know that's not the case i don't
know you i know the people that i'm like
talking to yeah you know i actually have
an understanding because it's like face
to face
you know
you